what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
20124 brought to you by filo filo is an
incredible company that puts the green
light control in the hands of creators
and fans if you want to learn more about
filo check out their website
film. I'm so excited right now you all
know this I will happily say this on
camera my old ass I just love saying my
old ass too my old ass is my favorite
film of Sundance 2024 I want all like
the good distribution Vibes to go your
way because I want to end the Year by
calling it one of my favorite films of
the year my heart was bursting at the
seams oh you're so sweet thank you know
how much I love the Fallout too it's not
like I went into this movie not
expecting it but I feel like like the
emotional wallup and the way that this
movie inspires you to rethink your past
present and future is just like that's
not an easy thing to come up with or to
convey via film so my God
congratulations you oh my goodness we be
the publicist for the
film wonderful team wonderful team I can
promise you here to promote all you want
um clearly I love your movie A lot of
people will first learn about the film
via Sundance so would you mind doing the
honors and giv giving a brief
description of my old ass yeah um my old
ass is about 18-year-old Elliot who does
mushroom comes to celebrate her birthday
uh in the Canadian wilderness and has a
trip where she meets herself at 40 and
her played by Aubrey Plaza iconic and
her 40y old
399 am clarification 39 uh and uh her
older self tells her some things that
happen to her in the future that don't
sound too great to her and kind of sends
her on a bit of a tail spin so so smart
I have a big complicated two-parter
about the journey from first feature to
Second feature cuz feel like a lot of
people out there think that when you
make one good film the second one should
come easy and that's not always the case
what is one surprising hurdle you had to
overcome to make this movie happen but
then I also kind of want the opposite
something about the reception The
Fallout got that did make my old ass
happening and happening the way you want
it
easier I got to make this movie because
of the Fallout you know I was we it had
a lot of success at South by and we were
so fortunate that HBO bought it and it
was amazing and a lot of great people
saw it and so I had a meeting with lucky
chop our amazing producers just they had
seen the Fallout and wanted to meet and
just generally kind of chat and during
that conversation they were like well do
you have any other movie ideas and I'd
been thinking about this idea but I was
like I don't know if anyone's going to
let me make it and I just loose pitched
kind of a log line to them like I just
did to you on the zoom and they were
like that sounds really interesting like
let's talk more about that and so
basically from there I I I started
building out the script and working with
them on it and then we found our amazing
financiers Indian Paintbrush who are
just incredible and give so much
creative freedom and just really are all
about supporting the director's Vision
as our lucky chaps it was the dream
situation um so that was the great thing
and that was what kind of came on the
heels of the Fallout and I think
probably the most difficult part of it
was the pressure I put on myself because
I was already feeling like I didn't
really know what I was doing with the
fallet and was shocked it's that it
worked and then you know I had this
amazing opportunity and you know my
husband's a musician and like the
sophomore album thing is like yes a
thing oh my gosh yes and I was really
feeling that with the second feature
whereas when I was making the Fallout I
was just like who let's see what happens
like I just was ignorance was Bliss and
this time I knew the stakes and so that
was that was the most challenging part
was getting out of my own head and it
was obviously a big step up in many ways
just all around um from that movie to
this movie the stakes were a lot higher
it fell higher so so good as as a
perfectionist who puts a lot of pressure
on herself I get the mentality but I
don't know you just watch these two
movies and you know with certainty that
there like there's some like natural
ability there that like it's there it
exists and it will follow you to every
film you make yeah thank you I mean I
mean it all right Maisy I'm coming your
way F not only your first feature but
it's your first feature and you're also
number one one on the call sheet when
you are presented with that opportunity
what is the scariest thing about that
and then how do you overcome those fears
and Tackle this performance with
confidence oh I think I mean the
scariest thing about being like a lead
in anything just in especially my first
project I think it was just knowing that
like you kind of have to carry it in a
way and if if you don't have um uh any
type of spark then it's not going to
feel alive and it's not going to uh be
enjoyable to watch and so yeah that I
felt a lot of um but the the people that
were on it like really were like holding
a lot of the pressure and like a lot of
the weight for me and I I honestly
didn't feel it uh like you know weighing
me down or anything
um but yeah I mean it was definitely
being being number one on a call sheet I
would look at it every day and like it
just I just couldn't believe what I was
seeing um but yeah I think tackling it
with confidence had so much to do with
Megan and I've honestly like felt so
conf andure in the script like the the
the script was so so good that like I
just knew that it was all everything
that we needed was like there and the
confidence that I had in Elliott was
like 100% cuz like I just knew that that
uh it was all there already so you just
gave Megan and the the team and the
environment credit for sure Kara Megan I
want you to give Maisy some flowers
right now so again like I said f first
time in a feature film leading a feature
film what is something about her for you
as a scene partner and for you as a lead
actor in your movie that you really
appreciate it and you're excited for
more actors and more directors to
experience with her in the future you
take it first I don't have a ton of
acting experience so I can't really like
I don't really have much to go off of
but from what I have experienced so far
I would say that sorry I sound like
Beyonce a little bit I would say that um
Maisy was I really appreciated how I
didn't feel I didn't feel like someone
was trying to outdo me I feel like
sometimes like at least in like training
environments everyone's like I'm about
to I'm about to eat you up or I'm about
to still the same from you like cuz I'm
trying to be the star of whatever like I
it's so competitive and even sometimes
like working with on the very few
limited projects I've done um working
with like whoever's higher up on the
call sheet than me it it it sometimes
feels like uh I don't you like you're
where you're supposed to be because
you're where you're supposed to be and
like you'll get here when you get here
but like this is where you're supposed
to be and with Maisy it just felt like
it just felt I just felt warmth I don't
know I just felt so warm and when I feel
warm I feel safe to like stretch when
you're cold you know you might pull a
hamstring or something but like when I
don't know I just felt really warm thank
you beautiful answer for me Maisy is one
in a million truly and I will say for
this film the cast ner said they never
had more submissions for a role in their
ever in their career and had really long
successful career and when we saw
maisy's tape and I I knew Maisy because
Maisy had created a song with her sister
for the Fallout and I already knew that
she was best friends with Maddie so we
had we were already friends and friendly
with each other um but I always knew and
hoped that like what I saw in her was
but it's what not always doesn't always
translate you know you can't always um
bring that to life on camera and when I
saw her tape I was like already could
see the trajectory of her career and I
think she is one of the most talented
actors I've ever met on any side of the
camera that I've worked on and I'm so
proud of her because the pressure is
huge to carry a film and she did you did
handle it with so much grace and there
you know it wasn't easy and the the
energy it takes to come to set every day
and do that and I think that the this is
only she's so amazing this movie and
people have only seen a little bit of
what she can do I'm telling you and I
just am so proud of her
and so break over here so easy to work
with and effortless and down to play and
every single person that had been in the
industry for years they came to Margo
Robbie you know Aubrey Plaza these
people they were like holy you know like
I remember Aubrey pulling me aside and
being like this is I'm she said to me on
set Maisy just made me fall back in love
with acting doing a scene with her
because she was just this having that
type of scene partner and that's what
Maisy brought to the set and created
that environment and it was so
refreshing Fring to work with somebody
who is so real and I hope every director
out there gets the chance to work with
you're winning like the arm chill game
that we said you're in the lead you're
in the lead right okay cool no I I can't
wait to watch what she does for the rest
of her career I'm right there with you
anything you touch I'm there I'm coming
back your way because I told you before
I am like I'm obsessed with you your
energy in the movie was electric and
then you hit the stage and I'm like oh
like that's just real life too I need
more of I want our audience to get to
learn a little bit more about you so a
two-part acting question for you going
into this film what was an acting goal
you had for yourself and now leaving it
what is a new goal you've acquired for
your next
film damn I would say an acting goal I
had coming into this y I would
say you know what's crazy is I don't
really set goals I just kind of go with
the flow um like even when I when I
moved to LA I I don't have bucket list
or anything even vision boards are
pretty hard for me I don't really set
goals I just whatever comes my way I'm
just grateful uh cuz I just like to
create art so I think when getting
this when getting this I said this in
another interview but it's not like I
had a lot of I don't have a lot of
offers like no one's knocking on my door
like the phone is dry unless it's like
my friends or like you know like a Uber
Eats or post notification just wait till
see but like on the real though like no
I be chilling like I really be chilling
and I be Incognito if you find me I'm in
the corner like with a dog and so
walking into this movie yeah shitu Taco
shout out Taco but walking into uh
walking into this film I would say
because I had faced so much I feel like
life problems at that time my I I called
you crying on a zoom one time and I just
couldn't hold it in she was like how are
you and I was like good and I just
started crying and she was like oh no so
I think when I walked into this my only
goal was like as a person just to like
try and like get some friend fresh air
like literally and also metaphorically
and like to just to just be in the
moment as much as you possibly can so
that was that what's the second part of
the question the second part is is now
that you've done it and you've had the
experience do you have you don't like to
set goals but it was to do you have a
new acting goal that you want to go
after on another film as a performer or
like to work with someone as a I I'll
take either actually see my shot right
now yeah this is the moment this is the
moment I do genuinely call this the
manifestation table oh [__] I like to
make things happen here you like to
manifest I manifested I would say um one
of them is to work with Coleman Domingo
and Jordan pill and Angela Basset please
and I would say as a performer is to uh
get even more
crazy I love everyone you just named
Coleman is one of the most lovely
individuals I've ever met in my life and
he he was a producer on my second
favorite film of this Festival it's what
inside so I am going to to manifest you
working on a film that his company
produces take a meeting a meeting I'm
into I'm so into this idea now that
you've said it it will happen and I will
be sitting there watching it um Maisy I
have to ask you about Aubrey first I
heard when I was watching the film I
kind of assumed that Aubrey had probably
been cast first and got involved in the
beginning and then you said it was the
opposite so what was it like finding out
that like you grew up to become
God that was like seriously the best
news of My Life um yeah I mean I was
cast first which is wild like you would
think obviously that Aubrey was cast
first um so it was interesting cuz like
our you know we're we do play the same
person um but I was already filming for
like two weeks so my my Elliott was
already kind of little Elliot was
already kind of established in in a way
and so um when Aubrey came in she kind
of came uh more to me but yeah no she
was like literally we were going through
a bunch of names and it was like a thing
of who looks most like Maisy and um like
more we were looking kind of in physical
aspects and then we just like at a
certain point like just like dropped
that a little bit and was like
energetically what um is the most
endearing and who do we love like who do
I I remember we had a conversation and
we were like who when you look over on
the log do you want to see sitting next
to you and who's like and saying that
first line yeah and we're like Aubrey I
me Aubrey I genuinely think Aubrey is
like the most like legit I think so many
people try to do her and like be like
her but she really was the start of this
whole like she just has such a unique uh
just everything about her is so special
and um she's like I just feel like she's
the most original legit and so I was so
excited to work with her and so nervous
and they have such a similar energy like
even though they're not exact physical
matches like there are so many qualities
to them that are really similar and
sense of humor and when they met it was
like very magic you know you could just
you could see the chemistry right away
yeah we I love her a lot I think yeah
that was definitely a thing of we were
like is it going to be so obvious that
we're so different and then I don't know
I think it watching we really did and
like watching it back I honestly that's
one of my favorite parts of the movie is
how different we are and how she's like
just a little bit like of a toughened
like hardened version of what you would
be at 18 which is I'm sure what will
happen to me too and that was that's
just what happens um but yeah I I honest
like think our differences turned out to
be like really sweet and endearing and
and such a perfect pairing it works so
well oh amazing Meg I want to come back
to you to talk a little bit about lucky
chap Indian Paintbrush the the companies
that you were working with because I
always think it's important to to
emphasize when those big companies
support a filmmaker in their Vision the
way that they need so what are some of
the things they did for you that helped
you exceed your own expectations for
your work on this
film I mean I the this the bar has been
set so high for me it was truly um every
director and Writer's dream situation
where I got so much invaluable advice so
much support really smart and thoughtful
insightful notes and then so much
Freedom um they really know how to
support their filmmakers that's why they
get so much repeat business I'm doing my
next movie with them um it was a really
really it was a pinch me situation it
makes me so happy yeah I feel very Lu to
be working with them and they have just
and everything that is coming to them is
so deserved they really treat what I
will say is Onset it's like they treat
the star the director and the pa the
same they're so wonderful and supportive
and kind human beings first and that
really comes across and and you know
after years of working together you see
cracks like if it's not genuine it's so
genuine it's so so genuine they're
lovely humans and so much fun we had a
great time as well they know how to they
you know throw dinners and and we would
get to boat places and they really know
how to create a really warm environment
for everybody to feel comfortable and
again like I said the bar has been set
pretty high for me now no like truly
makes me so happy to know companies like
that exists it's just like a brighter
future for this industry and we need to
highlight them as much as possible
speaking of which I'll lean into my filo
question which kind of TAPS into that so
filo is all about putting the creative
control in the hands of the creators so
whether it's on this film or any project
you've worked on can you each recall a
time when you got creative control and
you didn't expect to get it oh my gosh I
I think that so much of I felt that so
much in this um movie I think like Megan
just her writing I think like honestly
as like young actors there's a lot of
scripts that you read that don't land
and don't feel right and don't feel like
super uh natural and like Megan's
writing I think for all young actors
that read it it's like literally
chilling because you just feel like
you're reading like genuine conversation
it's not um it feels mature but still
young and it it it like just really
shines such a nice light on this
generation I think that doesn't happen
that often honestly in film now um but
sorry what was what was the ACT you were
leaning into it quite beautifully the
idea of getting creative control when
you might not expect to have it that is
where I was going was that Megan really
because she wanted to feel so genuine
and so real for this generation she
gives a lot of creative control to the
actors um and I think like that was so
huge for us like I know for Maddie and
Percy as well like it to to feel like
yourself and to feel um like that
freedom is really I know how rare that
is and and that was something that I
think all of us like is one of our
favorite things about working with mag
again mhm 100% anything you want to add
um yeah I would say uh
it's well besides like me giving myself
that creative freedom with my company
that I just made I would say it's
definitely this movie because like she
said like people um tend to uh people
tend to have
difficulties
um writing for young people because
that's their target audience they think
that like okay let's lean super into it
but I think that I think that what Megan
touches on so beautifully is that there
is no such thing as
like there's no such thing as like a
young genre is just a young person
you're just a young being you're like a
human being just being like you are just
being and so I think that she allowed us
to just be and actually be human beings
and this that gave gave me so much
license as a performer and as a person
yeah it makes it a lot more enjoyable
like genuinely it makes it feel much
more like just like Sparky and like
you're you're watching real people which
is my favorite thing to watch in in
movies and that's my favorite style of
film and that's definitely yeah you give
a lot of a lot of like that description
like reflects how the movie treats
coming of age and where someone is at at
any point in their life yeah I think
also a little bit of this for me as when
I was acting I was acting at their age I
like never felt in control most of the
time I I maybe once or twice in a career
of 10 15 years did I ever feel that um
so I definitely am trying to curate that
kind of environment and trying to write
maybe redo history a little bit not
every situation I was in as an actor but
certainly the majority um and it
frustrated me and I'm trying to create a
different vibe so important I mean we
need more people who will take their
past experiences and use them to make
the future better for all the artists in
this industry I'm going to end with a
couple of questions inspired by this
concept I'm sure you're being asked a
lot like what would you tell your
younger self I tried to like switch it
up a little bit if you had the
opportunity to re-experience a memory
from your past what memory would you
choose and why oh my goodness experience
and not change it no not change it just
you know relive it maybe reprocess it
for some reason re I would just want to
go back and relive one day that was
totally normal as like a six-year-old
like just like morning till night like a
summer day swimming in the pool good Pi
hanging out with your family like as it
was when you were a kid eating dinner
playing with your friends just like the
simple things not a care in the world
yeah not a care in the world that would
be going to bed in your like childhood
bed yeah getting tucked in
like um makes me want to cry we're all
like oh [__] um me and my sister have
like talked about this memory all the
time because we can't figure out if it
really happened or not um because where
I'm from in asosa it's like in Ontario
um Canada of this really small town
and and there was this one day we were
at our friend's house and they had like
all these little like back weird like
like Ro not even Road just like little
paths everywhere and we went on a little
Adventure we packed our backpacks we got
our Band-Aids and our snacks and Lennon
had her little guitar and we just like
went adventuring and we found this in my
memory it is a Bob Ross painting it is
the most beautiful site I've ever seen
and we spent the entire day there and we
all literally just played our guitars
and just hung out and then the next day
we tried to find it again and we
literally for for weeks we tried to find
this place again and we couldn't find it
and we all are convinced that it was
like literally a a magical mystical
little like fairy tale it was so
beautiful and me and Lennon talk about
all the time like did we literally make
that up or did that happen so I would
relive that just so I could prove that
uh that that wasn't a dream and that
that really happened and our friends
remember it too it was literally like
God it was so beautiful I would I would
go back there definitely if you believe
it happened it happened it happened I
swear it I feel like if more than one
person remembers it dude I could draw it
I could literally draw it from memory it
was like so beautiful but yeah that's my
answer um for me specifically I would
say yeah me and my brother used to just
ride our bikes around with these uh
neighborhood kids in our neighborhood we
call them the Rugrats and that's cuz
they always got into a lot of trouble
and stuff and we used to just ride our
bikes around and just like just be rug
just be just be rug terrible in the
neighborhood so I relive one of those
days for sure Rock Solid choice I have
to look let you go soon I'm going to end
on like a kind of silly one that just
crossed my mind if you could re visit
your favorite discontinued snack what
snack would you choose discontinued and
then I Googled a million discontinued
snack snacks and like my heart broke
that these things don't exist anymore
I'll go first mine will be the serial
straws they used to have like flavor on
the inside and you like sucked like milk
out of them you know
suck wait that's such a good question I
honestly every snack is discontinued to
me cuz all my favorite snacks are
Canadian snacks and they've been
discontinued cuz I don't live in Canada
anymore um so in that regard like all
dress chips ketchup chips crunchy bars
any type of Canadian snack so Superior
and to me that has Smarties that has
been
discontinued yeah well they're discon
for me CU I live in the states and I
can't get
anything so yeah wait what are your
Smarties like they're like M&M's just
chocolate little colored this we me and
Lena got into this the other day cuz we
were confused cuz they're rockets in
Canada called here they're called
Smarties like the little like ply things
yeah yeah are dunkaroo discontinued so I
I know this information cuz I was
looking it up dunkaroo I think were were
discontinued but then in 2020 they were
brought back so apparently they exist
but I would have chosen dunkaroo that
would have been my choice I was never
allowed to have them as a kid but I
would like trade them you know those so
good we had a lot of J like my my pick
was probably Kudos they were these
granola bars that were like pretending
to be granola bars but were really candy
bars cuz they were covered in like
either candy or like drizzled in
chocolate so good so good that's such a
good question I you have really amazing
question the best amazing amazing movie
deserves the best questions the best
press the best distribution the best
audience I am willing all of that in
your direction right now thank you for
sharing your experience with us today
and thank you for this movie thank I
mean it to everyone out there my old s
keep an eye out for it and stay tuned
we'll live more from Sundance 2024 for
you very
soon